so we're told that F of 2 is equal to 12
f prime of X is equal to 24 over X to
the third and what we want to figure out
is what is F of negative 1 alright so
they give us the derivative in terms of
X so maybe we can take the
antiderivative of the derivative to find
our original function so let's do that
so we could say that f of X f of X is
going to be equal to the antiderivative
or we could say the indefinite integral
of F prime of X which is equal to 24
over X to the third I could write it
over like this 24 over X to the third
but to help me process it a little bit
more I'm going to write it I'm going to
write this is 24 X to the negative 3
because then it'll become a little how
to take that anti derivative d/dx and so
what is the antiderivative of 24 X to
the negative 3 well we're just going to
do the power rule in Reverse so what
we're going to do is we're going to
increase the exponent so let me just
rewrite it it's going to be 24x to the
we're going to increase the exponent by
1 so it's going to be X to the negative
3 plus 1 and then we're going to divide
by that increased exponent so negative 3
plus 1 and so that is going to be
negative 3 plus 1 is X to the negative 2
and then we divide by negative 2
and if you're in doubt about what we
just did where we're kind of doing the
power rule in Reverse now take the power
rule take the derivative of this using
the power rule negative 2 times 24 over
negative 2 it's just going to be 24 and
then you decrement that exponent you go
to negative 3 so are we done here is
this f of X well f of X might involve a
constant so let's put a constant out out
here because notice if you were to take
the derivative of this thing here the
derivative of 24 X to the negative 2
over negative 2 we already established
is 24 X to the negative 3 but then if
you take the derivative of a constant
well that just disappears so you don't
see it when you look at the derivative
so we have to make sure that there might
be a
and I have a feeling based on the
information that they've given us we're
going to make use of that constant so
let me rewrite f of X so we know that f
of X can be expressed as 24 divided by
negative 2 it's negative 12 X to the
negative 2 plus some constant so how do
we figure out that constant well they
have told us what F of 2 is f of 2 is
equal to 12 so let's write this down so
when so f so f of 2 is equal to 12 which
is equal to well we just have to put 2
in everywhere we see an X that's going
to be negative 2 times 2 to the negative
2 power plus C and so 12 is equal to
what is this 2 to the negative 2 2 to
the negative 2 is equal to 1 over 2
squared which is equal to 1/4 so this is
negative 12 times 1/4 negative 12 times
1/4 is negative 3 so it's negative 3
plus C now we can add 3 to both sides to
solve for C we get 15 is equal to 15 is
equal to C so or C is equal to 15 that
is equal to 15 and so now we can write
our f of X as we get f of X is equal to
negative 12 and I could even write that
as negative 12 over x squared if we like
negative 12 over x squared plus 15 and
now using that we can evaluate F of
negative 1 F of negative 1 wherever we
see an X we put a negative 1 there so
this is going to be negative 1 squared
so F of negative 1 is equal to 12
divided by negative 12 divided by
negative 1 squared well negative 1
squared is just 1 so it's going to be
negative 12 plus 15 which is equal to 3
and we're done
this thing is equal to 3